i don't have anything at the top um uh
so let's kick off with your questions
okay thank you um
a couple questions about yesterday um
the president said uh one of the things
that's been cleared him the public
doesn't want to see him be president's
senator
and i was just wondering does that mean
he plans to step back from the
negotiations on the bill going forward
uh interrelated he talked about the
importance of him getting out of
washington and explaining his agenda how
often should we expect to see him out
and about america
well uh first i would say that one of my
favorite things i've done since i took
this job is to travel with the president
because he absolutely loves engaging
with people it's probably why he's been
in politics so long he loves talking to
people who agree with him people who
don't agree with him and i think what
you heard him say a lot last night is
what is reflective of what he's been
telling us uh for some time now which is
that he wants to do a lot more of that
what that looks like on the schedule
we're still determining that
but
it certainly means you'll see him out on
the road more
you'll see him probably bring members of
congress with him on air force one as
he's done recently and he's really
enjoyed the opportunity to be able to
have those free ranging conversations
with them on the back of air force one
and it means you'll see him talking more
about his agenda and what he's doing to
make people's lives better so we don't
have anything more to preview but i
think you heard very clearly multiple
times last night from the president that
that is how he wants to spend more of
his time moving forward but to go back
to the origin of your question their
armor it doesn't mean what it means is
um he has a talented experienced
legislative team some have said one of
the most experienced legislative teams
in recent history that is true and he's
certainly going to continue to rely on
them and probably rely on them more to
get a lot of the business done and
negotiations and work with congress uh
he of course is always going to be
someone who picks up the phone and talks
to people he's known for a long time
in congress whether they're democrats or
republicans and he'll continue to do
that but it's a reflection of how he
wants to spend his time and his
recognition that he wants to spend more
time out in the country and less time
behind closed doors negotiating is that
a course correction or a lesson to learn
from the first year of being on the job
and going through the cases
i wouldn't i wouldn't put it exactly in
those terms i would say that
it's a reflection of how
our own
of of his view which we share of how we
can best use his time and there's
nothing more valuable than the
president's time
so
but it also means bringing members of
congress with him on the road sometimes
having them listen to the american
people people who agree with them and
don't agree with them uh
covet obviously has posed some
challenges but that's what it's a
reflection of the second thing i wanted
to ask about yesterday
was
president biden said the midterm
elections
um both easily could be illegitimate
is it predetermining that the elect the
november elections are going to be
suspect well i talked to the president
about this last night uh and this
morning uh he was not intending to cast
doubt on the legitimacy of the 2020
election he was actually attempting to
make the opposite point which is that in
2020
despite covid despite many attempts to
suppress the vote a record number of
voters democrats and republicans
independents too turned out in the face
of a pandemic and election officials
made sure they could vote and have those
votes counted he was also explaining
that the results would be illegitimate
if states do what the former president
asked them to do in more than a half a
dozen states
in 2020
after the 2020 election toss out ballots
and overturn results after the fact and
his view is that what one of the most
important roles we can play now is
informing and educating the public on
what these laws are on efforts to
suppress their vote
and even beyond the laws
efforts in different states across the
country to make it more difficult for
them
good
thanks just to follow up on that the
president said uh
predicted that something would get done
in the electoral reform side senator
manchin said today that he had spoken
with the president about the bipartisan
effort that's going on relating to the
electoral compounds as well mr president
getting behind that effort are you guys
involved in that effort how do you see
that effort playing out given
kind of against that effort earlier
through the context of the john rosa
we've never been against it we just want
to be one have always wanted to be clear
that it was not a substitute for voting
rights legislation
which some i think we're attempting to
project uh and so especially as we were
working to get the john lewis voting
rights act uh across the finish line and
the freedom to vote act which do very
different things right i mean than the
electoral account act the freedom to
vote act creates standards for voter
access and voter registration outlines
criteria to make redistricting less
partisan
and strengthens campaign finance laws
the john lewis voting rights advancement
act establishes a new pre-clearance
process to ensure that certain states
and jurisdictions need approval from the
department of justice before moving
forward with changes that impact voting
rights
the electoral count act does something
entirely different so i think our point
is it's not a replacement for but
certainly the president is uh open to
engaging with talking with as we are um
even though it's not a substitute
republicans and others who are
interested in moving forward the
legislative question the president
talked about breaking up pieces and
build that veteran i think he understood
what he was trying to say there but just
for clarity for congressional process
nerds um he's still talking about we're
in dc it's a safe place lots of
processed nerds here scaling back a
single reconciliation package moving
that forward and then maybe voting on
things that are in that package is that
the context here well he wasn't
necessarily dictating what the size
would look like he wants to get as much
as big of a chunk as we can get done
done and through congress he also
recognizes that nothing is going to get
done without 50 votes so we're not
confronting a choice between what can
happen in our ideal it's a choice
between do we make critical progress for
the economic well-being of middle-class
families and in tackling climate crisis
or not so right now it's determining how
big that chunk can be through the
reconciliation process which as you know
as a budget nerd requires 50 votes if
you break different pieces apart or as
you continue to fight for anything that
might not be in there it would require
60 votes of course
and if there's 10 republicans who want
to support efforts of course we'd
welcome that but he's talking about
getting a big chunk as much as you can
get
done where we can get an agreement of 50
members of the senate and just one last
one we've seen the president's statement
the tweets in your statement last night
has there been any communication
directly to ukrainian officials um to
address any of their concerns that they
had after the president we have been in
touch at a high level uh with ukrainian
officials and leaders um as you may know
uh secretary of state has been in europe
he was meeting with ukrainian officials
a couple of days ago european
leaders earlier today and he's meeting
uh with his russian counterpart tomorrow
so we have been in touch at a high level
they certainly understand uh from those
conversations uh what the president
meant uh and you saw the president uh
make a statement or convey uh clearly
his point of view this morning which is
reflective of exactly what he said most
importantly to president putin go ahead
just to make it very clear has president
yesterday uh he has not uh he has spoken
with him a couple of times as you know
in the last month but we have spoken at
a very high level uh but below the
president let me ask you if i can follow
up on the questions
about voting rights and the integrity of
the election you said the president's
intention was not to cast out on the
upcoming midterms but when a reporter
followed up the president said to him
i'm not saying it's going to be legit
the increase in the prospect of being
illegitimate is in direct proportion to
us not being able to get these reforms
passed so yes or no does the president
believe it all remains as it is right
now that the elections this fall will be
legitimate
his vote yes but what he is what the
point he was making is that as recently
as 2020 as we know the former president
was trying to uh work with local
officials to overturn the vote count and
not have ballots counted and we have to
be very eyes wide open about that and
clear-eyed that that is the intention
potentially of him and certainly of of
members of his party
the president is satisfied even if
because yesterday obviously voting
rights hit a wall in congress right now
without without the votes for the
filibuster rules to be changed
and
given the conversation just had about
other avenues that could be taken if
there is if there are no changes in
terms of voting rights legislation going
forward the president does still feel
confident that the elections this fall
will be legitimate yes
uh go ahead thank you dad i'm just
following up real quick on this
legislative stuff yesterday the
president blamed republicans for
blocking his agenda called the
destructionist but he admitted that he
hadn't reached out to any um on the
issue of voting rights so now given
where things stand with these two bills
um will he be reaching out to any
republicans seeing that this bipartisan
effort on the electoral account act
might end up being the only game in town
on that well we don't accept that but i
will also say that there has been
discussions between democrats and
republicans for months now about voting
rights legislation they have been
invited multiple times a part of the
conversation reached out to engaged with
16 of them have supported the protection
of voting rights legislation in the past
and declined to do that this time they
are not uninformed about exactly what
this legislation would do and they've
always been welcome to be part of the
conversation they decided not to and i
think that's important for people to
understand
the question crime then i want to ask
about ukraine um ahead of the
president's meeting with the mayor's
conference tomorrow um some of the
biggest headlines this week have been
the new york city woman being pushed to
her death in a subway if the woman in
l.a being murdered allegedly by a career
criminal um i saw this morning that you
went on tv and reiterated the
president's position yes on fox thank
you for joining us uh that he wants to
fund police and you know make clear that
crime is uh something that this white
house takes seriously but you guys have
not weighed in on the actions from these
prosecutors
um so why hasn't the administration
waited on some of these new policies
from da's who are you know downgrading
certain crimes or refusing to prosecute
certain crimes
given that it could undermine some of
these broader efforts that your white
house is making to show that it takes
crime seriously well one there is a law
enforcement component and a justice
component of the federal government
right
the president has been crystal clear i
think and almost every time he's spoken
about this
that he believes that more needs to be
done by local leaders we're going to
support funding to ensure they have that
whether it's local cops programs or
other programs to support surge response
teams as we're seeing different kinds of
crime in different parts of the country
and that will continue to be what he
advocates for but i wouldn't expect he's
going to comment on or engage in every
local law enforcement action
um moving on to ukraine um bipartisan
members of congress from several
different committees this week uh have
been told in briefings that u.s
officials believe russia is likely to
invade ukraine despite this continuing
narrative that
has not made up his mind uh they're
saying that satellites signals
intelligence and human intelligence it's
all telling the same story what they're
seeing and hearing is about to happen
and the president's comments last night
seemed to corroborate that to a certain
degree where he said my guess is putin
will move in
so why wouldn't the us introduce
sort of level one sanctions um as
proactive deterrents and then remove
them if russia escalates well one i said
two days ago we're now at a stage where
russia could at any point launch an
attack in ukraine and we've been bit
pretty uh transparent about what we're
seeing both on our briefings but also in
our engagements with all of you and in
our conversations with our european
partners i would note that this morning
the treasury department did announce
sanctions on individuals who have
engaged in influence activities directed
by the russian governments this action
was part of our ongoing long-standing
efforts to counter russia's network of
influence efforts and to expose russia's
dangerous threatening and ongoing
campaign to destabilize ukraine uh these
individuals are at the heart of russia's
destabilizing campaign in ukraine and we
stand united with the ukrainian
government we are not waiting uh to take
action to counter russia we see what
they're doing we are disrupting it and
these actions are also of course
separate and distinct from the broad
range of high-impact severe measures we
and our allies are prepared to impose in
order to inflict significant costs
should they invade
the president said he thinks putin will
test the west
um
isn't that in some way already happening
and
why are we
spending this time debating what to do
after an invasion rather than
mitigate the risk of one
in advance of that happening especially
because this buildup is already causing
economic consequences for the u.s having
to send additional aid
shouldn't the threat of an invasion also
carry
serious economics well i just referred
to treasury sanctions we announced this
morning right we've also provided more
assistance to ukraine than any year in
history uh including defense assistance
those are but again we're what we're
making decisions on based on decades of
experience the president has and decades
of experience of our foreign policy team
and through consultation with our
partners on what is going to be
the most effective step president putin
is going to make the choice he's going
to make either he's going to decide to
invade ukraine and suffer severe
economic consequences or he's going to
decide to engage in diplomatic
discussions it's important to remember
who the aggressor is here the aggressor
is russia and putin they are building up
military troops they are uh pushing out
misinformation in ukraine that's who we
need to keep our focus on and make sure
we're educating the public about their
actions go ahead where did deliberations
stand on the broader economic sanctions
that you're planning has the president
given a final sign off on a package
i don't have an update on that i believe
steve that uh we're cons continuing to
consider a range of options and haven't
ruled out
any that have been reported uh but i
don't have an update on the internal
status
in touch with ukrainians yeah any allies
sought clarification of the president's
remark well secondary blinking saw his
european counterparts this morning i
don't have any i know he just spoke and
i think answered questions but i didn't
see the full totality of that
but certainly he reiterated uh what you
heard the president say this morning
what the president has also conveyed
directly to president putin and we have
been in such close contact i think over
100 engagements over the last several
weeks with our european partners and
counterparts uh with our nato partners
with the osce with the eu to make sure
we're working in in alignment and in
lockstep about how we're going to uh
approach any actions president putin
takes let's talk a little bit about the
possibility of another summit with
president putin what about a phone call
in the next few days just to try to
fix things
i don't have anything to predict on that
front steve i would say that you know as
you know last week there were three
rounds of discussions this week
secretary blinken is of course um in
europe and and there was also a
bipartisan uh congressional delegation
there the president has been in touch
with all of them uh i expect when
secretary blinken comes back they'll
discuss uh with the national security
team what the right next steps are
the president's gonna meet with the
japanese prime minister virtually
what are they going to talk about are
they going to talk about this recent
upsurge in missile launches by north
korea
uh i expect there'll be a range of
topics uh of discussion he looks forward
to meeting with
prime minister kushida to further
strengthen the us japan alliance deep in
ties between our economies and other
people and advance our vision uh
including about a free and open indus
pacific and that includes security i
think we're going to have a preview call
later today i expect
so i will leave it to our experts to
give you uh more details and information
go ahead hey thanks jen i'm just a
follow-up on going out into the country
um you know biden conceded that he
needed to do more um but i know that
there are already folks that have talked
to them who are disillusioned with the
last year i wonder if there's a special
message that goes out to them or does
the white house worry that it's
disillusioned some people you know from
ever coming back into the fold
do you mean members of the party or the
voting rights groups black voters in
safe places like georgian south carolina
yeah look i think the president you
heard the president say last night
several times i think that he was deeply
disappointed that voting rights
legislation didn't move forward you've
also heard him say and he would repeat
this to advocates who have been fighting
so hard since the 2020 election
that he's going to fight until his last
breath to ensure there is voting rights
legislation that passes i know today
marks one year but that does not mean
our work is done nobody's packing up
their bags uh we are continuing the
fight and continuing the work ahead so
that's what he would convey uh to those
advocates uh i think what you will see
him do
and again i don't have anything i know
um asked about this is uh you know be
out there doing what he's done for many
decades and people have covered him for
a long time know he loves engagement
i've never seen anyone who likes a rope
line or a photo line as much as he does
having conversations with people and
some of them may be people who care
deeply about voting rights some of them
may be people who care deeply about
their small business or health care or
whatever it may be or maybe a
combination of all of those things
has uh the white house had any
conversations about an executive order
that would do what hr 40 does the one
that was study preparations
uh i i can check on that and see if
there's anything to update you on go
ahead thank you i'm joy delay from
bloomberg yes real how are you good to
see you again good to see you um when
will the white house engage in new talks
with senator manchin on buildbackfighter
last night he told reporters that no one
has contacted him
well i think as i've said here uh before
we are not going to read out or detail
all of our engagements with every
senator including senator manchin um and
we are in touch with every senator at a
senior staff level uh that is true but
of course he's a key part of getting
legislation across the finish line and
and uh you heard the president convey
his desire and interest in doing exactly
that will a new go back better proposal
be forthcoming without the expanded
child tax credit
i'm not going to prejudge uh what it's
going to look like the president
proposed an extension of the child tax
credit because it's something he very
much believes in it helped cut the cut
childhood poverty by 40 last year that's
significant a lot of families helped a
lot of families get them some breathing
room help them make ends meet
but again what the president knows is
that there is agreement in congress
among democrats about a couple of things
doing more to lower costs lowering costs
for child care for health care
negotiating with prescription for on
prescription drugs and we got to figure
out what we can get in a big chunk of a
package to get it across the finish line
but i'm not going to negotiate from here
go ahead thanks i have questions today
on east asia and also on iran starting
with east asia and the upcoming us asean
summit
can you just talk a little bit about
how important asean is for us policy in
the region and how you view specific
asean members
in in those goals in context of those
goals well i think what you've heard the
president talk about before as it
relates to how he was going to approach
and even if we reflect back on the first
year
rebuilding our partnerships and
alliances and some of those are through
pre-existing structures like asean some
of them are through direct bilateral
relationships has been a priority for
the president from the beginning because
he thinks it will strengthen uh our
objective of advocating for uh uh huma
for
for human rights uh for uh for global
security uh and for even working in
conjunction to address big global
problems right like
like the global economy or the covid
crisis
in terms of the exact agenda i don't
have the details of that yet i'm sure we
will preview it as we get
a bit closer uh but you know it's
another opportunity for him to have
conversations about how we can work
together and how we can rebuild a lot of
the relationships that were uh destroyed
over the last the four years prior to
him cool then quickly on china before i
move on to iran um the president said
yesterday that he's not ready to lift
tariffs on chinese imports but the
chinese ministry of commerce fired back
and said that if he were to do so it
might ease inflation and make things
easier for both manufacturers and
consumers in china and in the us is that
a tool that he might consider to fight
inflation well we're doing undergoing a
review of all of these um and looking at
how they impact
different industries that effort is
being led by ambassador tai as you know
some of them have not heard industries
some of them have and we're certainly
but i don't have anything to preview on
that front it's it's really being led by
ambassador tai and finally on iran the
president was quite optimistic yesterday
what is the source of his optimism has
he received any assurances from iran's
supreme leader
and is the u.s planning to deliver on
the guarantees that tehran is seeking
well i think it depends on what iran's
willing to bring to the table so uh the
president is always going to uh you know
he believes that diplomacy is the first
best option uh and we are uh engaged uh
i believe it's the eighth round of talks
now if i'm remembering my numbers um
eighth round of talks uh and we are
going to see uh what happens he also
several weeks ago asked his team to
prepare a range of options as well so
that uh that has also happened i mean
there are realities though here of what
we're looking at because of the decision
by the last president to pull out of the
iran nuclear deal which means iran is
much closer to
developing the fissile materials they
need they are we don't have no
transparency or visibility as we had
when we were in the deal uh there have
been more attacks
around the world
on our allies and partners so there are
some realities of the challenging
circumstances were in because of the
decision made by the former president
and his team at the time i would remind
everyone promised they would negotiate a
stronger deal that these things wouldn't
happen that was not true so here we are
we're in the diplomatic negotiations uh
and we've been very clear about uh where
we stand on what we would agree to uh
but again i don't have anything to to
read out for you beyond uh beyond the
status of where they are now
go ahead
hi ken thanks i want to excavate your
statement last night that came out after
the president's press conference you
said um in that president was aware the
russians have an extensive playbook of
aggression
short of military actions including
cyber attacks and foreign military taxes
was the implication is that statement
didn't quite say it when the president
used the words minor incursions he had
the paramilitary
actions and the cyber
yeah
so
and he should and later on he said cyber
attacks right but not in the first
answer
so um
are we to conclude from that then that
paramilitary action and cyber attacks
would not necessarily trigger
the full sanctions
or get unanimity within nato to do that
because that was the context of
his minor incursions well i think david
and obviously you closely covered as
others did back in 2014 as well so
there's a that was a reference in part
or what he was doing is referencing what
we've seen in terms of tactics during
that period of time and since that time
of course right the little green men
cyber attacks etc um you know i think he
uh we have a range of what he was the
point he was making is that we have a
range of tools right i'm not i'm not
going to outline for you here what if
this what if that i think what should be
clear to everyone and i think he was
very clear on this this morning is that
if russia if president putin decides to
invade ukraine if they move
military
troops
military
across the border that's an invasion and
there will be severe economic
uh consequences we also know that we
need to be prepared for a range of
scenarios and we have a range of tools
and tactics uh at our disposal obviously
we just announced sanctions this morning
and they have not invaded so
i'm not going to parse more than that
other than to convey that we've seen
them use a range of tools
what he was very clear about this
morning is that if they assemble russian
units if they move those across the
ukrainian border that's an invasion
there will be severe and economic
consequences on a nato uh
what he was conveying is that uh we have
been focused and ensuring that we remain
united with nato now united uh doesn't
mean that everything will be identical
right it means we're united and taking
actions should they decide to invade and
we are united and you've seen uh leaders
from europe convey very clearly that
there would be consequences even as
recently as this morning
is
for five or six years even back to when
you were uh in the obama administration
you may recall there's been an effort
to try to bolster particularly cyber
deterrence by not making a distinction
between what you could do with the cyber
attack and what you could do with a
physical
attack and obviously the russians have
turned off the power of ukraine twice
2015
2016 they messed with an election in
uh
in ukraine before they came here
so i'm just trying to figure out the
president's trying to make a distinction
that we would use lesser forms of
penalties for cyber attacks or
paramilitary action than we would for
going over the border in other words
are we diminishing
what what over the years two two or
three administrations are trying to
build up in that sphere
our intention is not to diminish
our intention is to be very clear about
what a military incursion would mean
now in terms of what the range of
options are at our disposal obviously
we've taken actions seen and unseen
announced and unannounced on cyber in
the past and we reserve every right to
do exactly that and we're certainly
the president is very cognizant of the
threat that cyber attacks we've
experienced them here of course posed to
the united states opposed to other
countries around the world
but i think it was uh to provide uh
clarity and directness on what he what
he conveyed directly to president putin
go ahead jen uh two questions on the
president's remarks about ukraine
one president biden has repeatedly said
the words of a president matter so why
isn't he more careful with his remarks
well i think the president gave nearly
two hours of a press conference last
night
what we conveyed this morning last night
and this morning was exactly what he's
conveyed to president putin and i think
what's important to the american public
and tell me if you agree or disagree is
what the president's positions are and
what he means uh and that's exactly what
he uh provided directly this morning
i was already planning to go on fox news
looking forward to in fact take the time
to send out the tweets do the meeting
appearances does that doesn't take long
to send out a tweet promise you
but does that take away from the
administration's ability to send a
consistent message to international
allies and the american people i assure
you that our allies and partners uh know
exactly what the president's position is
they knew it was yesterday they knew
during the press conference they knew
after the press conference because we
have been engaged uh closely and working
boxed up them for weeks on the rising uh
military uh encourager threat posed by
russia uh say they know exactly where
they stand they ha they always have and
they certainly do today
go ahead
hi uh jen two questions uh first one
what's ahead i attended the gop house a
leadership
press conference today on biden's one
year oh boy
did they have lots of good stuff to say
well minority leader kevin mccarthy
rejected the idea that the president
floated yesterday that republicans are
blocking his agenda he said the white
house has not approached them about his
agenda outside of infrastructure what's
your reaction to his words that you're
not working with republicans and what's
the pathway forward for his larger
agenda items if there is going to be a
breakup of buildback better
i would say that if uh if mr mccarthy
wants to come over here and have a
constructive conversation about
more we can do together to put people
back to work to protect people from the
virus
to put in place more
smarter security measures at the border
we'd be happy to have that conversation
i don't think that's a comment he made
that's entirely on the level given uh we
certainly have engaged with republicans
across the board the president of the
united states himself has and so i don't
think that really bears out in fact well
to his point though the administration
or senate democrats at least democrats
however first uh proceeded with go back
better through budget reconciliation
they approached it with the intent that
they would need only democrats to get
that agenda done again for this question
looking at chunks what's the bipartisan
plan moving forward well look in the
history of reconciliation and the use of
it uh it's been bipartisan about 20
times
you can't it's not the rule you can't
vote for it if you're from the other
party that's not the rule at all um and
if anyone's telling you that that's not
true uh i would say that what's
perplexing to us
uh and maybe somebody asked mr mccarthy
this or not is are republicans now
against negotiating uh lower
prescription drug prices are they now
against lowering the cost of child care
are they now against lowering the cost
of elder care i mean if they allow us to
claim all of those things on the
democratic side we'll take them but it
is a little perplexing that they would
uh they would allow for us to own all
the ground on that one last question
from our hawaii bureau i don't think the
administration has spoken on this yet
but
has the president been briefed about the
oil spill and what's
the action to to address that um i can
check with our team i i believe he
probably has been briefed on it but but
let me check with our team and see if we
can get you an update after briefing go
ahead
um thanks jen
three questions if you can kill me first
um in response to my
uh colleague on uh crime you said uh
local leaders more needs to be done by
local leaders is that going to be part
of the message tomorrow when the
president meets with mayors that
you know this is an issue that is under
their control and they need they need to
handle it so it doesn't
sort of come back to you
in the way that it seems to be doing
well that's not exactly our message i
mean actually what uh we've conveyed
very clearly in the president's budget
includes is a plus up of a lot of the
funding for the cops program for example
significant plus up about several
hundred billion dollars from the last
president because we know that local
communities local cops programs need
that funding
there's different
crime challenges in different
communities it is important for local
leaders to step up if
if they see crime in their communities
there's a lot the president will discuss
with the mayors tomorrow i haven't had a
chance to look at the remarks yet and
see if that's a part of it
um second question um
there's a conversation brewing that i'm
sure you're aware of um about the
direction of the democratic party and
it's no longer just sort of confined to
the sub stack
discontents
uh the times uh has this focus group
that they
uh
uh
that they published a sort of transcript
of with right that frank luntz um your
favorite pollster held in one voter no
issue with franklin
and what one voter says i just want to
send a message i think the democratic
party is nuts at the moment and the only
way i can send that message is with my
vote and then another voter response to
that yeah the progressives have taken
over the democratic party um
i just want you to respond to that into
the broader criticisms that the
administration is being moved too far to
the left and that could
present challenges down the road for you
well i'm not going to respond to
individual people and focus groups but i
will tell you that
the president's view and our view is
that
his agenda is one that is broadly
popular in the country
among many progressives but also among
many moderates and frankly many
republicans who are maybe not sitting in
this zip code but are members of the
public writ large
and that's because
negotiating the price of prescription
drugs is something people think is long
overdue uh that's because a lot of
people can't afford the cost of child
care it is prohibitively expensive that
is why two million women in part why two
million women are not in the workforce a
lot of people don't know how to afford
elder care especially when they're
paying for also for child care
people don't know how to get universal
pre-k for their kids or they can't
afford to do it they put them in daycare
make them making them less likely
by data less likely to graduate from
college those are things that are
american issues they're not democratic
or progressive issues and his agenda is
broadly popular across the spectrum uh
we also know that um
that there are challenges uh that the
american people's going through a lot
right now um you know and we've talked
about this before but
obviously we're at a point where we're
still fighting a pandemic we didn't
think we'd still be there that's
frustrating to people no matter what
wing of the party or whether you're a
republican it's frustrating to everybody
we certainly understand that and we know
that's why we need to focus on getting
the pandemic under control and
continuing to address costs it gets to
my final question and i appreciate being
here with that sure
so let's if we climb to like a higher
altitude than you know crime trends or
polls or
um focus groups how much of
just the key to this administration is
just getting through the pandemic and
getting through it in a way that is safe
and responsible and then we can all sort
of exhale and say this is done and is
there a sense um
and i have a feeling there is that other
things will fall into place
once you get through covey because it
seems to me that you guys are paying a
political price for the fact
that this pandemic just does not end and
people are frustrated and
for
any number of totally legitimate reasons
but they're taking it out specifically
on you
well we we know um that covid uh the
fact that we're still finding a pandemic
um
is on the minds of nearly every american
of course it is it impacts their daily
lives and how they're living their lives
you know they can't go to concerts or
restaurants you worry about your kids
going to school um you know and life
doesn't look the same as it looked a
couple of years ago
the president believes and you heard him
say this last night that we can get
coveted under control and covet as it is
right now is not forever it does not
have to disrupt our daily lives right
now of course we're in an unprecedented
surge we have the tools but we believe
we have the tools to protect ourselves
our communities our schools and our
businesses and everyone needs to be
unified around these tools that is our
focus um but cobid right now
as it is right now is not going to be
what it is for forever and that's what
we're working to get to the other side
of there's no question that addressing
the pandemic is the top issue on
people's minds you know because we've
discussed it here that governor polis in
colorado last month said emergency over
is there a sense that
a similar message
from the president could
i guess sort of help with the sense that
we are
you know we are progressing even if we
are clearly still in a pandemic but some
people thought poet's message was
irresponsible but others
celebrated it and i wonder what you make
of of that shift in tone from a fellow
democrat well i think the president of
the united states has a responsibility
not to make that statement until the
data and the science backs it up and
when it does he'll be eager to make that
statement i would note that colorado
still receives a range of federal
assistance uh to ensure that people have
tests uh masks uh vaccines uh and so uh
you know that's still part of uh how
they're working to address the pandemic
go ahead
if i could go back to uh ukraine sure
when he made those comments yesterday
about the minor incursions he said
something along the lines that those
types of minor incursions would uh
require some more discussion with allies
as to whether or not to
respond to them
he
did say this morning that there was a
wide range of options to to respond how
much of agreement is there if we're
putting aside full-blown invasion how
much agreement is there between allies
and the united states as to
whether or not to respond and
how like what type of
response should be there
i mean you've heard a lot of our
partners and allies in europe say
themselves that if russia invades there
will be a strong
and consequential
you know impact
and that is steps they will take steps
we will take as i said a little bit
earlier we are united united doesn't
mean identical um and that's something
deputy secretary sherman has said and i
think it really clarifies uh what we
mean but we are very in very working in
close lockstep with nato with our
european partners with the osce
and there is clarity and resolve and
united commitment to take
coordinated united uh steps should
russia invade it seems that this unity
is very clear and obvious and public on
the invasion part
not so much if we talk about other forms
of aggression is that right
well again uh there are as the president
said this morning and as i said in
my comments obviously there are a range
of tools at our disposal as there are a
range of tools at the disposal of our
partners um and we are prepared for a
range of steps or actions the russians
could take and we've seen this playbook
before i'm not going to outline each
step and what that may mean but that is
all part of the discussion uh with our
partners i couldn't just one
much bigger picture since it's the
one-year anniversary
if you take all the foreign policy
elements that happened the pull out of
afghanistan the iran talks russia
the office deal and the crisis with
france how would you assess that first
year when it comes to foreign policy
well i would say what the president is
most proud of is rebuilding our
partnerships and alliances around the
world that had been frayed for some time
and he said this publicly but when he
has traveled around the world or engaged
with foreign leaders
they are relieved that a respect for
democracy respect for alliances is back
they are worried about how long and that
is how frayed the last president left
those relationships but rebuilding that
and re rebuilding that trust is a big
basis of what he's proud of um and he
believes as you touch in a couple of the
uh of the items you did one we have a
long and abiding relationship with the
french they've said that so i don't
think it's accurate to say it was a
crisis um two uh he still stands
one that he felt we were fighting too
long and
uh
i don't remember
was but i
alliance
i'll obviously
that have been ordered
uh
all these
probably the need for more
orders
or
a treatment
or
cost more
some
decision
as to whether or not there's another
request coming from omb and whether or
not
uh there's any sort of unusual uh
supplemental funding that's going to be
needed is there any update on where that
stands and when we may see anything on
that front well as speaker pelosi said
last weekend and we agree with this
we're never going to let uh resources
stand in the way of addressing the
pandemic i think i paraphrased that it
was different words but you get what i'm
saying um
and that remains the case uh we have
what we need to fight this moment in the
crisis uh but we have continued
discussions and engagements with
congress about what we may need and part
of what we've done to date is make sure
we are not just preparing for the moment
but we are ahead right so if you look at
even the order
of the antivirals you know we knew
that once those pills were approved they
would be a game changer we worked to
expedite the process by several months
and we made a huge order
so we are always looking ahead to see
how we can ensure
we are prepared and have what we need as
often as we can but i don't have
anything specific to preview for you in
terms of a request
on a completely different topic that i
don't think has come up here yet today
a federal grand jury in indiana
yesterday uh indicted a man for the
murder of a
police detective who's part of it who
was part of an fbi task force
uh the charges that
the individual was indicted on would be
eligible for uh being a federal capital
case
uh and i am wondering whether or not
uh the president given his position on
the death penalty intends to uh
intervene in any way regarding the uh
attorney general's decision on whether
or not to pursue that as a capital case
or whether that is up to the discretion
of the justice department well it's
always up to the discretion of the
justice department but the president's
view on the death penalty is well known
as you know the justice department is
undergoing a review uh which is i have
nothing to preview on they they can
speak to that in the status
okay thanks everyone
[Music]
many records broken job creation press
conference length you know
thanks everyone